let's talk about this here's we have
this uh indiegogo you launched and
here's what i find truly interesting
about this so this is your exile
documentary series exposing the global
crisis of religious and ethnic
persecution but the first thing i want
to talk to you about is
you're trying to shop this documentary
series around to these networks
and they're telling you outright
yeah but can you do it without
criticizing china so they're telling us
two things hey that's good product and
then secondly can you do it without and
so it's hey that's a good product can
you do it without talking about china
and secondarily the gulf states and um
i'm like so my exact words the first
time i heard this were you know we could
do a beetle stock without talking about
john but it would suck um so what so uh
first tell us what this is like give us
the elevator pitch and what it's about
and then you know why why china
you know why they're upset about your
criticism no human being should have to
live in the place of their birth with
fear that stems from their faith their
ethnicity or race their sexuality or
what have you this is this human
fundamental right to live without fear
in the place of your birth now if you
want to move move i was in syria
speaking to some members of the
christian community from the cabal river
valley and a representative and i said
if i could give you anything which i
can't that you want what would it be and
he's like send all the christians back
and i'm like hell no no never
but i would like to help make a world
where they didn't have to fight like
hell to leave to begin with right nobody
should have to live in fear based on
deeply held convictions or immutable
character traits
yeah pause for dramatic effect that's it
so so why why do we live in a world
where where 80 percent of the world
lives in fear of religious persecution
which we do eight out of ten people
right that's four out of five for those
of you who went same school i did um and
i i just that's because nobody freaking
knows i just got to point out i i i feel
for the white male christians in this
country who are suffering the worst
i'm not looking over at sheamus he's
looking directly
but wait a white irish what are you
talking about yeah
but yeah so so
i just kind of backed into this and i
and i'm still friends with some people
in dc shockingly and and these guys and
gals don't know this stuff nobody knows
this stuff but if we understood just how
bad this is right i wish you guys could
i mean
in three and a half minutes we kind of
sort of shine a light on how bad this is
how pervasive it is and and the other
thing is like we talked again off air
hubris is when you say it can't happen
here that's like the last thing anybody
says the titanic can't sink it's
unsinkable
oh [ __ ] right this boat's in trouble and
so we want to show these stories because
all too often the west the united states
even and i love this country right i've
served it in uniform i've served it
locally state and federally and it's not
as cool as it sounds um but the united
states has all too often been complicit
we've either turned a blind eye or
actually helped the people who were
hurting their minority populations oh
yeah definitely well so so i definitely
want to get into that
but in detail but uh how is it that you
know china plays a role in this and and
why is it that i mean i imagine you
criticize america to a certain degree i
just did right but so so are these
networks being like oh don't criticize
america no they're saying don't
criticize china well because in america
you can criticize america but in china
you can't criticize china right in
america
right
apparently right um in fact there's a
cottage industry built around keeping
americans from criticizing china um
irony shout out to mark cuban everybody
right and everybody wants
we should boycott the beijing olympia
it's like maybe we should but that ship
has sailed what would be freaking
awesome is for one of these amazing
young men and women who's worked their
whole lives to be so good at this is to
earn a gold medal to use that podium in
beijing to stand up for freedom and
human dignity
right well that's not boycott jesse
owens jesse owens sent the biggest
possible message to the nazis when he
kept winning gold medals but didn't they
ban protest outright so like no black
lives matter stuff no anti-china stuff
they got to have a medal ceremony right
who were the guys in in was it 68 who
raised their fists right my i i i
personally would i think they should
boycott it you know i mean
i think they might should have but it's
too late we could have replicated this
we're pouring money and and fuel onto
the propaganda fire that is the ccp that
that that is literally so i'm doing a
fox news interview right you think
they're playing to the right and they go
well on the screen are the 10 biggest
defenders of religious freedom and i'm
like oh how do you have that list
without china on it wow i mean
everybody's weaker muslims yeah dude
it's the uyghurs of the tip of the
iceberg so they've been organ harvesting
from the fulangang in china for for
decades there's there's two churches in
china there's the state sanctioned
church that does as they're told and
then there are the people who huddle it
and this is not hyperbolic who huddle in
fear in in in their kitchens in groups
of two three five
because they want to actually learn the
gospel right so the chinese are the
absolute worst because why because for
communism and totalitarianism to succeed
the state must be paramount and faith
whether it's judaism or islam or
christianity says that there's something
bigger than you and me and indeed the
state and the government jesus was such
a threat to the empire dude right and
and and so they they had this script for
how jesus was supposed to play and he
didn't play by it and it's also why in
north korea they're told that what is it
kim's kim il-sung or whatever created
the universe or something like that yeah
is that true right divine i read that i
don't actually know but we did have um
yeah we had young me on right now
did she did you talk about that i can't
remember the specific details on what
they what they're told to believe yeah
all i know is that she came out of there
not knowing what love was because they
had so thoroughly brainwashed her and
there's no chance of developing any kind
of faith outside the state in a place
like north korea where are some of the
hot spots around the globe as you've
been studying this so nigeria's been
horrible for 20 years and it's never
talked about right again like
i served uh in the military i did uh
eight months in a tent in bosnia during
operation joint guard joint endeavor
largely because christiano allen poor
told us truly and she was right how
horrible it was when 8 000 muslims were
massacred at srebrenica
and half a million people are murdered
in rwanda over ethnicity before the u.s
and the world get up off their hands
right so so africa is terrible there's
like a line of blood across africa as
radical islam and not islam i have
wonderful muslim friends who have helped
me not die
um sort of creeps southward um myanmar
burma is is one of the worst so in in
this the second world war we promised
the burmese minority groups which is
about 45 of the country you get 55
percent uh burmans and then you've got
kachen and wah and karen all these
ethnic tribes which are either muslim or
christian
and and so the the burmese had never
lost a fight the british came in
subjugated them the japanese came in the
burmese are like let's get the british
out we're on your team the minorities
the british and the americans go to the
minorities and go if you help us get the
japanese out we'll make sure you have
autonomy and self-determination when we
win and they did they fought bled and
died next to americans and british
soldiers and then the war ended and we
said yes a lot anyway and left and the
burmese civil war started in like 1947
and it's still ongoing right
right and so you hear about the rohingya
but also there are the kachen and the
wall and the koran and and so this has
been going on for generations um
south asia is horrific right modi has
absolutely weaponized faith because he
understands that even though they have
240 million muslims and millions of
christians and even a jewish community
etc in india that they've got 870
million hindus so it's a big we they
paradigm
if you're an amity muslim in pakistan
that is muslims who believe that there
have been subsequent prophets after the
prophet muhammad you'll be murdered in
public and often without recourse if
you're a christian in pakistan uh the
christians in afghanistan now and he's
we're talking about tiny slivers right
again the formulaic sort of totalitarian
game is to pick a minority group big
enough that everybody thinks they know
somebody from it but small enough that
it can't defend itself what are they
doing to the christians in pakistan
driving them underground right there was
a great uh story about a pastor sahil
latif who uh i was able to tangentially
help uh who was locked up because he was
advocating for the rights of the
impoverished in karachi not just
christians but muslims as land grabbers
came in saying oh this is the next place
that we want to invest and then
systematically essentially did title
fraud on all these people who had like
10 square feet and so sahil latif
speaking up for him and they put him in
prison and shut down his church right so
like it's brave just to be a christian
there
to be a christian who stands up and
leads so it's even it's even it's
arguably stupid but the backstory was
when he got out immediately they said
well you need to move i mean
he shouldn't have to move right so
that's exile is if we tell these stories
right i'm the naive guy because it's a
lot easier to be naive than than to be
worldly
i if we tell these stories i think that
that the people of the west won't
tolerate it if the people of the west
demand their leaders act differently
then they will act differently and if
they do act differently we can change
the world without putting boots on the
ground without spending money
do you want to do economic and security
business with the u.s you do good then
stop throwing your homosexuals off
rooftops dumb ass right stop persecuting
your christians stop displacing your
muslims when george bush junior invaded
afghanistan and then all of a sudden we
had this muslim pro it was a problem
with muslim it was all of a sudden it
felt very racist towards muslims in
islam there's a lot of hate 2003 4-5
what did we have a sikh that was shot
because an idiot thought he was a muslim
so how do we being implicit in that
because sometimes i'm like take the
plank out of your own eye before you try
and fix your neighbor like
there's a definitely some sort of
problem here in the united states
obvious it's global it's beyond nation
oh yeah yeah how do we kind of unwind
our own races do you see it anyway as
part of the same problem like we need to
so if we are able to do exile at
excelsiors.com if we are able to do
exile we'll do an episode here in this
country because we do have very real
problems with prejudice and
discrimination right they're not
necessarily would have been identified
by the groups that claim to speak for
the oppressed groups um
but this is this is so simple and again
we i think off air talked about like
well they say it's too simple i think
we've overcomplicated things
you simply say that as a point of entry
to do economic or security business with
the us you have to pass these these
civil rights criteria you may not
segregate or or or or disallow the
participation of any group based on you
know
sexuality race religion etc and and as a
and i think it works because the world
has to choose between getting in camp
with the west in the us or china and
china doesn't they don't borrow they
take right it might look like borrowing
so i think it works the the example i
always like to use is turkey during the
cold war i think i already spoke to this
so we needed to control the bosphorous
right because we need to keep the
soviets black sea fleet from sneaking
down in the mediterranean and wreaking
havoc in europe so we said turkey we
want you on our team and they said cool
we want to be on your team meanwhile
they're persecuting their christian
community they're absolutely decimating
their kurdish community they passed a
law these are our nato allies the turks
who subsequently in the last five years
actually put under siege a u.s base and
held americans hostage and it never made
the news
where there were new
technical nuclear weapons but i digress
so they passed a law that said there's
no such thing as occurred and the u.s
didn't do a darn thing about it i'm
going to guess that if you say to turkey
you can go be with the soviets or you
can be with us but the price of being
with us is not oppressing your
minorities that they're still with us
i take that gamble there's there's
challenges in um
you know how much the united states
should be policing other countries so i
think boots on the ground i would always
be opposed to right but then there's the
question of us knowing what's going on
in china with the uyghur muslims and
then doing business with them anyway
right and people like mark hugh mark
cuban and lebron james being like oh we
gotta stop insulting china and it's like
no no no no no like dude we don't we
don't want to go invade china or
anything like that but we don't need to
like be buying stuff made in xinjiang so
my head's gonna explode right because
people go oh muslims dude isis killed
more muslims than they did christians or
yazidis right it ain't even close
so and people go oh you're insulting
china you know who suffers the most
under the chinese regime
the freaking chinese
right so don't tell me that by me
speaking out against an authoritarian
regime that stymies their compete their
people as it suits them i'm anti-chinese
i'm anti-oppression we we do have a uh
you know these amount of viewers i have
a lot of friends who are very much proud
isolationists they're like nope
america's for america we should focus on
america we got to not be involved in
that stuff and i don't agree um i'm not
you know i think there's a there's a
there's a happy medium between like
boots on the ground in a foreign country
because they're concentration camps like
china and hey china we decided not to
buy those you know cloths from you
because you have concentration camps
this is totally liberty based foreign
policy it really is i'm not advocating
for boots on the ground anywhere i'm
advocating for not doing business with
oppressors right now things will happen
that we will not know about and things
will happen on varying scales and and
certainly hard and fast rules are tough
sometimes but we have absolutely
positively turned a blonde eye over
decades and the world knows it if and
this should like here's the thing
i'm tired of the partisan back and forth
rhetoric that are wrong and we're right
and this and that and the other we
should be able to unite under the idea
right this is what exilesseries.com is
all about
that you should be able to live in the
place of your birth without fear left
and right should be to get behind that
and if the cost of it is that we choose
to do business with people who treat
their minority groups and their majority
with basic human dignity right
who who can who can't get behind that
well but we don't because nobody's ever
said i guess then the solution or maybe
you're suggesting the economic sanctions
against countries no just don't do
business with them yeah i guess that's
talking about instead of the government
it's more of an individual choice like
you're inspiring individuals so i so
when i buy a clock radio i i to this day
and i don't buy clock radios anymore
because it's 20 22 but i'm old but so
when i buy a product to this day i'm
gonna look on the box and try to
ascertain where it's made and if i can
buy a product that's made in malaysia
before i buy a product that's made in
china i'm buying the product made in
malaysia and if i can buy a product
that's made in the united states and i
pay a little bit more to be fair i'm
going to buy that one too um
when i was in the military i used to say
i don't want to pay for the bullet that
might be used to shoot me because
another little secret of the chinese is
the actual military apparatus owns a lot
of the means of production so you could
if you're in the american military and
you're buying products made in china you
ironically enough are
paying for weapons that will be pointed
at you
so yeah it starts with the individual or
if you're a taxpayer i mean just with
all the coups that we funded and
everything that's gone in the middle
east and how we end up fighting rebel
groups that we funded so it's like yeah
ultimately american troops are just
going to inevitably be shot with bullets
that they paid for it's pretty insane
and without gratuitously piling onto the
debacle that was the afghanistan
withdrawal it is not a question of if
but when americans are killed with
american weapons yeah i mean it's not
it's just gonna happen if it hasn't it's
already furious obama's whole
cartel's guns thing man talk about
failed leadership they've literally
prioritized the political agenda over
the lives of their very citizens
and and in the case of what we're trying
to address at exilesseries.com they've
politicized profit over the lives of
their fellow human nobody cares about
the uyghurs was refreshing because
somebody told the truth
and
the co-owner of the golden state
warriors
people were ragged on that guy because
they were like how dare you say that and
i'm like what be honest with everyone he
didn't say i personally don't care about
their plight he said come on nobody
cares about this let's be honest which
is right and i'm like nobody that should
be the clarion call they buried the lead
yeah we we talk about you know uh the
weaker muslims concentration camps
fairly frequently and it's it's
remarkable how for one a lot of people
don't know and a lot of people do
literally don't care and i'm you know
like i said look i know it's not easy
for the average person to find that
solution but try to buy american even if
it costs a little more and there's a
happy medium like i said between
invading the country declaring war and
just being like you know you shot that
disney movie
in the province with the security forces
of concentration camps we're not gonna
watch that movie no but people don't
don't know or care yeah well and if
everything i was discussing earlier you
know the fact that these hollywood
screenwriters and executives at these
studios actually hate you and your way
of life isn't enough to encourage you to
stop purchasing their products
they're also in league and catering to
people who are running actual
concentration camps for real right yeah
i mean like that's not hyperbolic that's
not hyperbolic so you asked earlier um
what's the elevator pitch and of course
i would like to wait 20 minutes to
answer questions
the elevator pitch is hollywood won't
make this movie
this this stock series they won't and if
you go to excelsiors.com shameless plug
and you click on that trailer and you
don't think that's freaking world-class
product right to tell these stories
it may be the best but you did insult
china so i'm sorry we can't fund your
project it reminds me of like a vice
stock in the early days of ice and they
were just like in the darkest places how
much money can we make if we air this we
can make money how much money can we
lose if we air this we could lose more
what's the right thing to do make money
holy crap we're screwed right that's
where we are and it's just i mean like
can you believe it that's not that's not
rhetoric and you believe it if we're at
the point where uh and we are where
these big networks are like let's make a
movie but don't offend china china's
winning china's one and then and then
what i mean they're they're they're some
of the worst human rights abusers on the
planet what was it khrushchev and i'm
gonna butcher the quote he said i will
you will manufacture the rope that we
use to hang you yeah right again when
money drives you with money and not
justice and that which is right drives
you
it's like the free hong kong stuff you
know when the nba wouldn't allow you to
make a free hong kong jersey to order
or the hearthstone player it's a card
game held up free hong kong and they're
like get them out of there and you know
there's look i do think there's some
rational argument and keep politics out
of some of these things
but
when the nba can't like you're trying to
buy a custom jersey for yourself and
you're like i want free hunk i'm like no
or there was that guy who got kicked out
because he had the free hong kong sign
at the nba like yo american corporations
it's i'll even say this
it's one thing
if you are like mark cuban actively
defending china it's one thing if you
are like
you know
look we don't want politics in here and
then it's it's funny when an american
corporation is actively defending china
from protesters in america like that is
just a whole new level scorpion is what
it's communism and cooperative yeah
right remember
you can use that one man yeah that's
great corpianism
well so like the left used to rail
against the corporations and now their
agenda is funded by and at some level
dictated by the corporations but we
won't go down that road um and they used
to stand up for free speech and now you
know you must adhere to the orthodoxy i
mean like
it's it's dystopian it's remarkable how
uh
you know one of the points brought up by
one of our super chatters the other the
other day was that they say black people
can't be racist but candace owens is
racist exactly i don't i don't i i'm
lost man you know i i'm i get it it
makes no sense on purpose i suppose but
sure whatever when i went into sudan
against everyone's wishes and and and
snatched these two guys out and met him
at the airport i didn't take a camera
crew because i'm a crappy politician
right because i felt like it would be
dirty to do that but meanwhile i'm being
called a racist it just it just baffles
me like i'm literally risking my life
again and again and again as as a white
christian male 1 for for for for people
of different races ethnicities and
faiths i wonder how many and i'm being
called a racist how many and throughout
time have been demonized that are
actually did good and like lucifer let's
take the worst demon of all
how how do you know that he was evil the
because history told you he did wrong
yes people talk because you're a racist
i can't stand the way propaganda works
against individuals the way they try and
tear people maybe i just thought you
were going to do the olinsky book for us
no but i think it'd be fascinating to
see you both do like your own
conversation on religion
you know hippie ian dmt spirituality
with you know sheamus christianity and
have that conversation and
you know be fascinating yeah it doesn't
have to be about the christian bible i
know that the bible is very divisive
about good and evil so i wonder if like
i think of that as propaganda too do you
think that's evil
what probably the bible's true about
good and evil oh yeah if the catholic
church actually devised a plan to
manipulate people that's evil well no
but you're saying it's too divisive
about good and evil is it like what's
wrong with being divided like what's
wrong with talking good and evil because
you if you're the one that gets to
decide what's good and what's evil and
you tell people like this is evil don't
then you're controlling people's
behavior but you're saying what the
church is doing is evil
has told me that i shouldn't consume a
product from hollywood but i've already
made a lock stock reference earlier and
i'm about to quote kaiser so say so
right the greatest trick that the devil
ever pulled is convincing us he didn't
exist amen so until you can until you
can identify some baseline for right and
wrong right
liberty is ultimately allowing your
freedom stops where mine starts allowing
people to make any decision they want to
for themselves until it begins to impact
others
and so um
what i'm advocating for is a world where
and we can all do that
but when you start hurting other people
then we have a duty i think particularly
people lucky enough to be born here to
say no no i can't i can't support it
we're literally supporting it that's the
thing it's it's not even a question of
going over there and do some doing
something it's just a question of not
supporting it so here oh should we go
intervene in ukraine hell no but we
should let the ukrainians help
themselves
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast if you
want to watch live you can check out
this channel monday through friday at 8
00 pm and don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
and if you want more unfiltered and
uncensored content with all of these
guests go to timcast.com and become a
member all of these guests you know and
love in exclusive segments on our
website where we are unrestricted in
what we talk about so you'll definitely
not want to miss it thanks for hanging
out we'll see you all next time